primeira a única pessoa no mundo eu já
fui em 70 países eu nunca vi
nenhum lugar as pessoas falam assim cadê
meu celular
só nós Porque nós tem ciência de que é
cinco minutos para esse celular tá em
quatro Estados diferentes do Brasil
a gente sabe tá ligado nós fomos criados
assim não adianta se você nasce em
Teresina se cresce em Teresina se cria
em Teresina mora para sempre lá você tem
a cabeça de Teresina Você nasceu em
Porto você se criei pouco você você
cresce você tem essa cabeça aqui pô não
tem como eu olho aqui quando eu tô numa
Burgueria eu já vejo a diferença o povo
tá comendo os hambúrguer o celular assim
em cima da mesa eu olho fico olhando
assim cara eu não sou nem ladrão dá
vontade de roubar esse pessoal aqui
Tá vacilando demais demais